hello I'm Peter S director of Disney and
Pixar's Elemental Elemental follows the
story of Ember a fiery young woman who
forms a surprising relationship with a
go with the flow guy named Wade who
challenges her beliefs about the world
they live in the film was inspired by my
own relationship with my wife and the
various challenges that came with being
from two completely different
backgrounds and cultures in this scene
we see Ember finally given a chance to
see something she's always dreamed of a
rare flower called a Vivia it means a
great deal to her because earlier in the
film we see a moment of prejudice she
and her father experien when they are
denied seeing the flower we decided to
put this scene in the film to experience
Wade's ability and desire to show Ember
that despite her feelings of not fitting
in the larger World there can be Bridges
to connection understanding and
ultimately
healing so this was one of the first
sequences that we had boarded in the
film we knew that we wanted Ember and
Wade to take a leap of faith together
but it was always boarded in this way
where there wasn't any dialogue between
the two of them could we begin to see
their relationship growing live in front
of us so much of the imagery here is
about trying to Showcase where Ember
belongs and where she doesn't the Arc of
this sequence starts with her jumping
into this dark place and there's it's
just her single light shrinking in the
darkness as the sequence rolls on her
light gets brighter and grows bigger the
more she discovers about the place and
the closer she gets to this moment of
seeing the
Vivia we left a lot of space here so
that the score could begin to lift the
audience out of their seats and to feel
this growing love between the two of
them when Thomas Newman first played
this track immediately you felt trust
sort of wrap around you and that ember
could trust Wade to jump into this
bubble that could kill her as we build
and discover more of this mysterious
space that they're going into this sort
of floated Subway we could just sit in
their feelings and grow with
it technically these performances really
needed to be executed in a way where we
can really begin to feel ember's healing
and Embers Wonder of what she's about to
see the team here did an incredible job
making these sort of breaks in logic
feel real and that's the whole game of
this film has been trying to push the
the audience to believe that fire and
water are real and not only that that
they can jump into these Little Miracles
of
sequences this moment here when Ember
lights up the entire room is showcasing
her light you know and that is something
that Wade has been falling in love with
in the entire film right when she
reaches that Pinnacle she gets to touch
a Vivia for the first time and there's
this look between the two of them here
that the animators created that it is a
gratefulness from Ember to Wade that
they captured that is so
beautiful Don shank our production
designer began to try to figure out the
rules of what was movie logic and what
was real space logic once he started
breaking that down he started trying to
unify the imag of what this bubble could
look like is it possible to have a
bubble of air this big be moved around
water like this his visual designs
really helped inform the effects artists
on how to then produce the visual side
of
this obviously when the air goes out
it's building up to this first
connection between the two of them which
was something that this whole film and
this idea had been building up toward
from the beginning from its early pitch
this concept of could they touch what if
fire fell in love with water could they
vaporize each other what could happen
and that question drove this entire film
from development to its final frames
here and when we boarded this thing we
didn't know what this was going to look
like there were so many technical
challenges to figuring out the look of
fire and look of water and the idea of a
chemical reaction where all the layers
that we were chomping at the bit to get
to it took a film to build up to this
moment the idea that could we get these
elements to represent
emotions and this idea of them touching
and the chemical reaction that happens
could that allow the audience to feel
that it sort of parallels what it's like
for you know humans for us to make
contact with someone for the first time
when you're touching someone for the
first time and holding someone's hand
and the Goosebumps that can form that
paralleling with the boiling and the
roiling fire on Ember as they sort of
push back and forth trying to find this
balance between the two of them so that
they can have this little miracle of
contact
GL